hey guys Ryan right here yeah I'm about
to watch the trailer you know continue
with the III fun let's watch the trailer
for Dead Island 2 I've never heard of
Dead Island
I like the [ __ ] title though I don't
even think people really asked me to
watch this trailer I just saw the title
when I was looking up some III trailers
and I was like that sounds fun Dead
Island hope it does so I'm gonna do a
zombies or something man it's just an
island full of dead people that sounds
scary this is not what I imagined Oh
what the [ __ ] was that damn graphics
have evolved so much oh [ __ ] look [ __ ]
is zombies
this looks really cool dude I love this
trailer very [ __ ] witty I love it
he's turning into one dude this looks
awesome
Wow
dude that looks [ __ ] sweet oh man I
am definitely buying that game I don't
know [ __ ] about the Dead Island series
whatever and I just was hooked
that looks amazing I am watching that
not I mean I'm playing that plant plant
alright guys well thank you for tuning
in with me and for the few people who
recommended to watch that thank you if
you're new to the channel strategy 5 I
try doing a zombie voice and I came out
like the Sith Lord in Star Wars
remember episode 3 no no yeah so this is
um the subscribe button enjoy it yeah
what was that oh you want to hear some
shoutouts ok
Zaid dance shout-out please man love
your vids bro
I love your dick enjoy it masturbate do
whatever you got to do John Wall he says
at the transformers age of extinction
trailer number 2 reaction could've sworn
I had my pants on at the beginning of
this video I'd bang all of you even the
dude in the middle especially the dude
in the middle I'm the dude in the middle
by the way give me a shout-out either
way you got yourself a new sub thanks
you [ __ ] you John man dude I
really appreciate this comet mainly
because you said you'd bang me sure
you're a guy and I'm not gay even though
a lot of people have been saying that in
the comment boxes lately but I'm not gay
not now I will admit there was a time
where I was very curious even
experimented a little bit realized
gawking for me now I never sucked a [ __ ]
barely even touched one but it was just
enough got a [ __ ] anyway now you
share something personal me John Lilly
what Little Willie [ __ ] man Little
Willie 10 little wily 10 make a reaction
to guardians of galaxy's second trailer
did that already check that off my list
also give me a shout-out well here it is
friend oh you finally got your shoutout
ask for this on May 19th in a while
telling you guys there's a lot of
shoutouts I gotta do Jamar Williams oh
yeah may I please get chop out I was
[ __ ] races I just saw Blood Diamond
yesterday cool [ __ ] movie by the way
and
I wanted to do that voice and Jamar
sounded like it would fit I'm assuming
you're black sorry I mean I'm not sorry
if you're black I have nothing against
black people black people are awesome
black people got the biggest dicks one
time a black guy wanted to suck my dick
but I refused not cuz he's black just
wasn't into it but I felt flattered
especially cuz he was black that man was
Jamar Williams